un trop plein de culpabilité et
d'injustice l'incarnation même de la
douleur profonde qui secoue la
communauté que jeune maire blanc de
minneapolis s'est recueilli avant la
cérémonie en hommage à georges claude
houze de sommeil dont il était un grand
gaillard que tout le monde aimait
définissent un des frères de tordre
floyd il arrivait à toucher tous ceux
qu'il rencontrait georges flow est mort
étouffé sous le genou d'un policier
blanc se dressaient contre toutes les
formes d'injustice ajoute son frère rené
pris un pli sérieuse n'est rien si sa
famille va se rappeler des généreux
qu'alain de droite claude de ses
sandwichs au fromage le référent chaque
militant de longue date pour les droits
civiques veut se souvenir de john floyd
pour mieux se tenir debout
mais enfin mais le temps est venu pour
la communauté afro-américaine de se
lever et de se libérer des genoux sur
son cou qui la maintiennent dans la
marginalité dit il huit minutes 46
secondes de recueillement le temps que
le genou du policier derecho 20 apaisé
sur le coup de john floyd de la torture
selon al sharpton et la famille floride
indoors made man who do you were blue
job lose your love you man space ou le
crâne yuko mais vous devez payer pour
vos crèmes
même si vous porter l'uniforme
clame-t-il à l'extérieur des centaines
de personnes venues écouter la cérémonie
sur haut parleur un pas dans l'histoire
que tiffany delà peut faire avec sa
fille de 15 ans tu netease
[Applaudissements]
minneapolis dit au revoir à droite floyd
ils le remercient à sa façon d'avoir
réveillé la société américaine après le
recueillement la ferveur renouvelée le
désir ardent d'égalité raciale